As we've seen relaxing the requirement to find the best possible solutions can allow us to find
polynomial time algorithms for NP complete problems.
At least some times, so approximability is something
that varies very much from problem to problem.
For some problems, we know that we cannot approximate them at all, unless P=NP.
Other problems such as vertex cover at least have a constant factor approximation algorithm.
And then there are those very, very well-behaved problems such as
knapsack for which we know polynomial time approximation schemes.
But what if still all of this doesn't help? Well, in that case, we will literally have to start poking around.
We'll be talking about randomization.